النداء نفسه الذي يكرره فلاديمير زيلينسكي
ولكن هذه المره بالتنقل وحضوره شخصيا
لمنتدى دافوس يحاول زيلينسكي جاهدا ضمن
عدم تراجع الدعم من حلفائه فبعد انقضاء
عامين تقريبا منذ بدء الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا باتت الانظار متجهه نحو الشرق
الاوسط نحن عازمون على مواصله دعمنا
لاوكرانيا ونتعاون بشكل وثيق مع الكونغرس
لتحقيق ذلك اعرف بان زملائنا الاوروبيين
سيقومون بالامر ذاته دعم سيكون حاسما لان
الجيش الاوكراني يواجه صعوبه فم عده اشهر
كثف الروس هجماتهم على الجبهه الشماليه
الشرقيه خاصه باتجاه منطقه كوبيانسك على
بعد حوالى 100 كيلومتر من خاركيف التي
تتعرض للقصف المستمر ما ادى الى اصدار
اوامر باخلاء 26 قريه في المنطقه الحدوديه
بالنسبه لقائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
فان قواه الاسلحه هي التي ستحدث
الفارق تظل اهدافنا دون تغيير الحفاظ على
مواقعنا
وارضينا وارهاق العدو من خلال الحاق اكبر
عدد ممكن من الخسائر
بقواته وقياده دفاع نشط من خلال اغتنام كل
فرصه هذا ما نفعله
يوميا ميدانيا كثفت اوكرانيا هجماتها
بطائرات مسيره على الاراضي الروسيه
الثلاثاء اكدت روسيا انها دمرت او اعترضت
خلال الليل مسيرات اوكرانيه عده فوق مناطق
حدوديه مع اوكرانيا في هجوم ادى الى اصابه
طفله